A lot of good investment has gone into the train station here in
in Limerick and the plaza and front,
and I welcome that.
But the rail line between Limerick and Ennis is closed yet again
because of flooding at Alikar.
And the government's failure to spend just 16 million
has really ruined the connectivity between Limerick and Ennis
and on to Galway.
If you impose carbon taxes on motorists,
you have to give them a viable opportunity.
Otherwise it's not a green tax,
it's just tax.
And it's all very well talking about public transport use more of us,
but we have no rail connection here with Shannon Airport.
Shannon can be a real hub for Galway,
for Limerick and even for Kirk.
Some of the flights could be from Kirk,
some from Shannon. But for that to happen,
we need the motorway between Cork and Limerick done and fast.
But we also should have a rail link for public transport
into this airport.